[Music]
and number one fan news
Oh submitted by David is my crush nice
thank you thank you so come on
David's mom stop it David you were
getting put in this article you'll say I
did David is so high 18 scream so hard
at a One Direction concert that her
lungs collapse she's so hard from sex
that her lungs collapse a team that's
the first thing that teens have sex all
the time
don't blame me but that's a category
important loudspeaker teen but see teen
porn category is not actual teens it's
just you're fighting girls who actually
look the age of the same team nineteen
seven this money to cause like you know
how they label it they say Oh teen
something something but it's like a
thirty year old girl I know that's
illegal one time I watched this one it
was a forty year old lady in a
schoolgirl outfit and I'm like I'm not
it they can't fall you that should be in
the milf category yeah you are not a
team as your hand is on your deck you
were clearly not a team okay so this
sixteen-year-old girl from Texas was
rushed to the ER because she was unable
to breathe the morning after a One
Direction concert happened but this case
study was recently published in the
Journal of emergency medicine Fox she's
special because the first time that's
real yeah so they've they've had like
documented cases in the past where you
have like lungs collapsed spontaneously
after weightlifting diving and military
flying but now they can add screaming at
a concert that's why I don't wait lift
you don't lift enough wait Stella
collapse no thank you for dropping my
self-esteem
did you really she wasn't suffering any
chest pain or
any other signs that could be wrong and
she had no history of lung conditions
and made no complaints of any sore
throat or coughing so like she had no of
the usual symptoms until blood came out
of her mouth or some people know until
then she started having trouble
breathing at that point like that's when
she was rushed there saying that after
the doctors examined her they noticed
that there was an unusual and this part
really creeps me out
an unusual popping noise under her skin
after pressing on her chest and throat
and so they discovered that like once
they they ran some x-rays on her or like
it sounded like a water bottle
it was kind of like like this apparently
they're saying like knuckle cracking
yeah so it's like a bubble burst thing
the same as like your knuckle cracking
how do you guys do that all you know how
am i doing my bad like that I never
crack my head crack my toes tonight
maybe I ain't got no air you don't have
any air I don't have no airs that's good
you don't do it because once you start
you capped my Shiro chiropractor told me
if you are gonna crack this Shiro don't
do this
just pull in this I was not pulling
point freaks me the [ __ ] out but this is
the way you're supposed to do it though
you release that so my that's how my a
Artie guy does it to really pull I can't
act you got supposed to doing this I
pull in the twist like that the only one
I pull is this one and then like this
pops right here this one I just go like
this and it pops on its own well they
went lucky so then they ended up
diagnosing her with small bilateral
pneumothoraces which is the slight
collapse of both lungs they're saying
that with the hole like bubbles under
the skin
combined with air escaping into her
chest cavity and in her throat all three
of those were diagnosed as separate
problems and so this is like a really
rare case because there has never like
it's been really rare to see someone
with three conditions and a young female
with no known underlying lung problems
one direction's fall but see this one it
is amazing
what some of these pop stars can do to
their fans the power that they have over
these we're talking about kpop like fans
right yeah the type of effect that music
has on people is insane like it makes
them feel as if they're meeting God
himself do you ladies remember a time
being a teenybopper and having those
type of feelings okay African think like
did you go to a concert is your favorite
Joey fat one no mistake my question is
how does that feel when you're in the
presence of the someone singer you like
and you just the [ __ ] turn into the
[ __ ] car sell [ __ ] and then you faint
and all that like what what is the
emotion that teenyboppers fear who do
you have a as of right now aside from
the significant other that you have who
do you have a [ __ ] crush on is it a
feeling like that back home is pretty up
there for me
oh so will you go like if David Beckham
showed up right now would you like heart
start pounding [ __ ] yeah I think I might
even melt them a little bit okay so yeah
that that feeling right that is that the
same team the feeling as although like
teenyboppers whatever probably yeah so
what is what is what is is it like
intense love is it intense what is it
yeah it's like I think it's a combo of
not really love fantasy admiration
admiration and then like like a greater
being you're in the presence of a
greater being like that what about you a
person that's not a cartoon I don't know
a thing you want Naruto I don't say that
Oh who's that guy that was in um
he was recently in a Tarantino movie but
he was like the only agent Bock's
know yo you are you talkin about [ __ ]
the Korean good dude yeah he's pretty
hot I know he doesn't mind yeah yeah you
let Korean guys oh he was also the GI
Joe dude is one of Korea's best actors
okay you're like what who in the world
would bring that out of you I don't know
that feeling that's why I'm trying to
understand because there are people that
I highly respect it and I was like oh
[ __ ] - [ __ ] Stevie Wonder Michael
Jackson if he was alive yeah like
someone that will immediately like
induce trembling in your body like you'd
be nervous to meet ya I don't know
because I never had that experience
that's why I'm wondering what what does
that feel like we're not cut out to in
back when you have this huge thing for
her was that you do I get to touch your
titties because back in a day because
maybe after at home that's that's what
dude I mean that's why I'm wondering is
it intense Loess is it happiness is it
thinking about it I think it's um I
don't know how guys work but with girls
it's like you're studying everything
about them right and you're like
emotionally finding some things they're
a stalker
no no like they don't have like so I
remember I had a crazy crush on the in
are DiCaprio right yeah but who's that
you're not my son got annoyed Leonardo
DiCaprio daddy dinner no and I remember
I would read like all his movie stuff I
read all his interviews I mused yeah I
was a bother to trying to find
similarities that its compatibility no
no no it wasn't even that it was just
like I was just so intrigued because I
liked his movies I liked his acting I
thought he was like super hot I think if
I would have met him because I know so
much about him and then just seeing him
like on paper or on movies he comes up
here says like you are very beautiful
oh dude I would die I would be like cuz
it's like I'm so invested in his life
who's that person for you now then I
won't have that now nobody I mean
no aside from the hunk of man next to
you I don't think I have that right now
do you think when women become but like
this I didn't know things about because
I have people immediately like even
though Bill Cosby is a rapist if I met
him I would probably cry no kiss for me
like I'm not upset I know nothing of
David Beckham there's just like just who
she looks like who he is what he sounds
like in a sexual or just like admiration
admiration she's like oh I account like
you get nervous if you don't regardless
of how you're right there no because I
think admiration and respecting
someone's skill set is very different
from the way fangirls idolize that one
is one is a complete shutdown of the
body and [ __ ] fainting and hysteria
and I mean maybe you will have that
reaction with someone that but I'm just
thinking that it's very very different
one is like I respect your skill what
you've done to this world one is I could
[ __ ] lick your sweat oh yeah it's in
the middle of both yeah for me because I
had this obsession like literally like
if you went to my room like it was
pictures of him everywhere like a serial
killer no I wasn't like that but I think
because I had time to really invest
myself and he became like a hobby to me
like me and my my my little friends and
stuff like we oughta thought we would
talk about like did you do that huh
that's crazy
no we were we were crazy dude so maybe
you didn't have that like with you're
not even over Justin Timberlake I was
never that upset I never a mess over
anyway you don't you don't have any guy
like that right right now yeah Wow cuz I
do cuz if I met Bill Cosby I met Dave
Chappelle I'd break the [ __ ] up I think
I'm agreeing with what Joe is saying
it's very different I do have people
that I admire but I wouldn't be like oh
oh my gosh but that's what I'm saying no
that's what she's saying though I admire
them and I would have that same reaction
if I met Dave Chappelle right now I
probably passed the [ __ ] out like that's
how much I admire him I think the main
point I'm trying to get is one is an
unhealthy obsession cuz the way that the
girls obsess is like a control
their life it's almost your experience
that right but it's like that kpop
obsession like these girls are willing
to murder the girlfriend but we're but
we're now we're assuming what that what
that girl is like though because now
you're no no no I'm just saying like
what does that feel like if you ever
experienced it I'm just talking about
regular fandom that's extreme for me it
was more of like a crush and it was more
on the on the sexual spectrum but then
what you're asking me I feel like at
least from my personal experience it's
it's nothing sexual at all and it's pure
and religious like you guys you guys are
adding to stuff that I'm not adding to
I'm saying like you meet this person and
you mean wow like this a lot of people
this girl she might have had a collapsed
lung at the concert that's a it wasn't a
collapsed lung right yeah when she went
home she probably had just been over one
direction
it's just then in their complete
meltdown she probably doesn't stock them
do anything because the definition is
getting crazy it's just that instance
you have people that just melt in that
instance yeah it's just a simple thing
like with her it's just David Beckham
like for me would be Bill Cosby Dave
Chappelle Chris Rock Eddie Murphy you
know yeah there's a lot of people for me
I'd be excited when I see him - yeah
yeah I probably because David Chappelle
is like my idol
hey guys I hope you guys enjoy the video
please remember to give us a big thumbs
up and a like like like and also when
you guys sign on YouTube make sure just
kidding news of the first thing you
watch every single day because we post
videos every day okay for more videos
[Music]